hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so i know that some of
you are a bit upset because i don't make
a gme or amc video every day but i'm
basically doing the videos that you guys
asked me to do that you want to see and
the truth is that what you guys ask me
the most are still amc ng me so today
i'm gonna make a video on amc and
tomorrow i'm gonna make a video on gme
let's get into it
[Music]
all right so we're gonna do this in two
parts first technicals purely so the
chart and second we're gonna check uh
all the information coming from the
option market
so here let me very quickly remind you
the big picture
so first wave bam you know this one yes
then we correct for three months then we
had another massive move up to the 70
area here once again for those who are
following me for a long time this was
respecting very well fibs and elliot
wave theory so this allowed me here to
find very precisely
all the levels and corrections that's
the reason why i'm gonna keep doing this
then in this whole correction it was
much tougher here to apply uh these same
rules because the correction is messy
and you know people just don't agree on
what to do but whenever it's going
higher everybody suddenly agrees and
it's following better the tools that i'm
using so since we had the breakout here
so here in this whole area it was uh
like i said very tough and
i had one a big fake out here that was
for me not easy not to fall in
then here the second breakout was very
good to use i gave you guys all the
information before it happened on my
discord and this followed very well
everything that is usually happening in
this kind of situation so what do we
have now i'm trying to apply once again
the same methods so elliot plus fibs so
here i'm trying to find five waves all
right so very clearly we have the first
wave bam it's from here to here so one
two three four five maybe not easy to
make a clean counting inside the first
wave but this is the first and since we
reached 48 we are here consolidating so
this is the second wave so question is
the second wave complete abc possible or
is it a larger maybe flat
uh or let's see what do we have abc
maybe so i'm only saying that uh to show
you that as long as we stay above 40 we
are still in the same scenario that
we're on a second wave then what could
also happen is that we go here higher we
would have such a you know cup and
handle pattern so if we break out of
course it's looking very good on the
other hand if we break out on the
downside this is looking uh really bad
so above fully
everything is very uh is looking very
good below fully we need to rethink
everything and see what was uh not
going well here but for now the upside
scenario is on
we are developing here in a bullish uh
way so higher highs higher lows as you
can see so this is bullish we don't have
any bearish divergence we almost had one
okay here you can see the momentum is
failing on the magazine okay so this is
not good whenever the market is making
higher highs here it's flat okay it's
slightly lower even so we don't have any
bearish sign as well so basically on the
short term nothing that bullish nothing
that bearish too but on the longer term
there are bullish patterns bullish
signals so my overall
view on this just technically just
looking at the chart is bullish and once
again
i have between 100 and 130 as a target
for this fifth wave how do i get those
targets i just
use elliott wave theory that is saying
that five is equal to a fib ratio of one
plus three so here it gives me it gives
me either one to one ninety five or one
to one point six one eight hundred and
twenty five and once again i can apply
it to the one plus three that is here
one two three or to the bigger one one
two three if i do for the bigger one it
changes slightly the targets with a bit
higher target hundred hundred and forty
five so we have roughly an area between
90 and 145 for the target of this fifth
wave so that's it for me technically now
let's have a look at the option market
it's very interesting so here
bam
gets it okay so i already have it so
here we have all the synthetic shot
coming from the option market so this
data is very uh interesting to analyze
because like i did for sprt with for
bbig i check where those uh options are
coming from and if it's coming from
short-term it means that it's a
short-term phenomenon if it's coming
from longer term it means that this is
going to last and amc is very
interesting look yes so once again i'm
not going to show you bbig and spr2 just
go check my other videos but those two
they were having massive open interest
on september and october when you look
at amc guys look so basically we're
looking for the big green numbers
it's where the options are coming from
then we're going to check which maturity
we can also see that for the small
strikes so here i am checking everything
below 50.
mostly it's coming from you know
september but
more in jan 22 right here we have around
a hundred thousand here we have 140 000
okay so we have slightly more for
september now if we go for higher
strikes
it's becoming interesting
bam look
145 so you guys know this one is
absolutely massive 20 million equivalent
shares all right so just have a look at
that
have a look at this chart guys
here so you can see i mean we are here
guys usually the option market is
concentrated around the money
look at the 145 strike i mean the number
of options is close to 20 million is
above 20 million and we have only uh
seven or eight million on the
40 strike here 9 million so yeah as you
can see this option distribution is
totally totally unusual and very
explosive on the upside now
if we want to know how long this is
going to last we check which maturity
it's coming from and you can see
yes
okay so half of it a 78 000
shares so it's like you need to multiply
this by 100 is coming from september but
look we have even more guys coming from
jan 22 what does it mean it means that
this is gonna last and probably
september so let's see what's happening
here uh i'm i'm curious to see how many
of those are gonna get rolled on the
october it's already rolling you can see
we have already three thousand here
options and we have here 80 000 roughly
so if it's getting all the world it
means that this will never stop so it's
very interesting to see and by the way
something interesting i wanted to tell
you guys is that you know some of you i
can see it in the comments you are upset
because i'm making videos about other
stocks but like i said at the beginning
of the video i'm just showing you what
you guys want to see second thing i want
to tell you is that many people on my
discord are actually telling me that
what do you think they're going to do
with the games that they get from bbig
sprt amy or whatever other squeeze uh
play they're putting everything in amc
so okay just keep this in mind that
everything in the end uh goes to the
right direction so that's it for me i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore i
see you guys